لم يشرع البيت الابيض مخازن وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه امام اوكرانيا مع بدايه الحرب
الروسيه
لكن تعثر هجوم موسكو والمقاومه التي
ابدتها القوات الاوكرانيه فتح شهيه واشنطن
على تزويد كيف باسلحه اكثر فتكا وتطورا
فمن العتاد الفردي وصواريخ جافلين المضاده
للدروع انتقل البانتاجون الى تزويد
اوكرانيا بالمدفعيه وراجمات هايمارز
وانظمه نيسانس للدفاع الجوي ومدرعات
برادلي وصولا الى التعهد بتوفير صواريخ
ودبابات
ياتي هذا الدعم في سياق تاكيد اداره بايدن
مسانده اوكرانيا مهما طال الزمن وتطلبت
الحرب لكن البيت الابيض يواجه معارضه من
جمهورينا لمنحه تفويضا مفتوحا في ملف
المساعدات
اعتقد ان الهاجس الاساسيه يتعلق بوجهه
الاموال ومجالات انفاقها وهناك جانبان
لهذا الهاجس فبعض الاعتاد العسكري يثير
تساؤلات تتعلق بالنيتور روسيا والجانب
الاخر هو ان جزء من هذا التمويل يبدو غير
واضح ما يثير حفيظه الجمهوريين فهم يرغبون
في مساعده اوكرانيا ومحاربه العدوان
الروسي لكن في المقابل يجب ان يعرفوه ايضا
الى اين تذهب هذه الاموال
ادام شعبي الامريكي للمساعدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه تراجع بدوره من 60% في مايو
العام الماضي الى اقل من النصف مع دخول
الحرب عامها الثاني
وبينما تهدف الزياده في المساعدات
العسكريه كما ونوعا الى تغيير الوقائع
الميدانيه وشروط التفاوض المستقبلي لمصلحه
اوكرانيا يرى خبراء ان هذه النتيجه ليست
مضمونه
لا ينبغي ان نتوقع حدوث تغيير ميداني غير
واقعي على المدى القصير فالعتاد العسكري
يستغرق وقتا للوصول الى اوكرانيا وهو
يحتاج الى ذخيره والى تدرب القوات
الاوكرانيه عليه لكي تستخدمه بنجاح وهذه
الامور لن تتحقق قبل نهايه الربيع او مطلع
الصيف وحينها يتوقع معظم المراقبين وانا
واحد منهم هجوما روسيا لاجبار اوكرانيا
على التراجع وفي ظل الهواه بين الاهداف
التي ترى القياده الاوكرانيه انها قابله
للتحقق وتقييم القياده العسكريه الامريكيه
لما هو واقعي تبرز تساؤلات عن المدى
الزمني للدعم العسكري مع تاكي د اذا بايدن
مواصله عسكريه لاوكرانيا
كره تتعلق بمجريات الحرب الروسيه وما
تستنزفه من القاعده الصناعيه الدفاعيه
لتحميل تداعيات محتمله على حجم هذا الدعم
ومداه الزمني فادي منصور الجزيره واشنطن